Andy Serkis is coming up next and you
are a self-proclaimed super nerd huge
I'm assuming you're a massive Andy
Serkis fan massive I I love him so much
and I we I've met him a few times we had
a lot we have a lot of friends in common
so I at one point I floated the idea to
my wife going hey I think I can contact
Andy Serkis
and have him be the ring bearer at our
wedding and and she said and you could
see this look on her face like I there's
still time to get out of this yeah the
guy could pull the report she was like I
think that's going a little because then
she also realized if she said yes to
that then I could also call up Mark
Hamill and have him cut the cake like
with it like I could call in every nerd
favor I have and just make it this whole
you know cacophony of nerdom would you
have Andy Serkis as Gollum going down
the aisle with the ring is the only see
that thing I was debating it do I ask
him to dress up as Gollum and it's to or
do I just have this Andy Serkis so my
nerd friends he looks like oh yeah I get
what's going on and the other people
like who is this British guy and they're
like we'll explain it like give my nerd
friends they think I'll explain later
you don't know what this is this is
really cool I get with them you're right
it's too much if he's going and he's got
the ring it's too much
yeah you like you don't want your
parents to get all of your references
you die you want your little circle of
nerd friends then you want to tell
something to your parents later you
could also have them come in dressed as
an ape on horseback that only you didn't
think of that
dammit no any frozen net over your bride
and I would lose her cuz I can't fight I
can't find my ape on horseback no God
you